welcome back prominent Democrats
defending Joe Biden after he adamantly
denied a sexual assault allegation
against him by former staffer Tara Reid
take a look there's been so many
investigations of this of the vice
president the most the most
comprehensive investigation of the vice
president was when he was vetted by
Barack Obama in 2008 Barack Obama
trusted Joe Biden I trust Joe Biden and
just because you're a survivor doesn't
mean that every claim is equal it means
we give them the ability to make their
case and the other side as well and then
to make a judgement that is informed I
don't believe that it's consistent with
the Joe Biden that I know and I do
believe Joe well I mean it's interesting
that the people who are trying to fan
this thing are the very people who
support Donald Trump former top Obama
adviser David Axelrod says the
allegation of harassment never came up
during the vetting process to select
Biden as vice president in 2008 and now
the New York Times is taking heat after
suggesting the DNC investigate the Biden
sexual assault claim Dana I was
wondering from your perspective where do
we stand now what do you think it is
because we've had David Axelrod say this
didn't come up in 2008 during a very
thorough vetting we've had the denial
last Friday from the vice president
where do we stand then well I think
you're seeing what's gonna happen is
that all the Democrats are gonna
coalesce behind Biden I mentioned on
Friday that if you didn't see over the
weekend prominent Democrats start to
distance themselves from Joe Biden that
that meant there had been a collective
agreement maybe unspoken may be spoken
somewhere that they are just going to
have to go for it defend Joe Biden and
it came out with a couple of things like
asking the DNC to investigate Joe Biden
would have been like asking Harvey
Weinstein's movie company to investigate
him and that does that doesn't wash and
then this idea that Joe Biden was more
vetted because he went through the 2008
vice presidential vetting then somebody
like Brett Kavanaugh who had mold
Senate confirmations for the US Circuit
Court and I know that judicial
appointments are political now but
remember when Harry Reid was head of the
Democrats and he had the majority in the
Senate they went after all of those
nominees and they if they could have
picked up something like that they
absolutely would have used it but this
is also what I think the Republicans are
going to have to get used to the idea
that the Democrats are not going to make
this a huge issue they don't mind being
called hypocrites they're going to grin
get through this and within a week or
two they'll be moving on to something
else so Jessie picking up on Dana's
point has the whole charge now been
effectively sort of de neutered or
neutered if you will for president Trump
or do you think there's any way he can
use this politically he'll use it I mean
there's vulnerabilities on his side but
he'll use it he's never been afraid to
do that it's funny that they think that
because Obama vetted Joe then he's clean
Obama can't vet I mean what about
Jeremiah Wright he sat in that guy's
pews for twenty years had no idea he was
a racist hater
then there's Gretchen Whitmer who says
both sides get to make their case when
his read gotten to make her case she
hasn't even been invited on a show to do
an interview Jo only made his case once
and a lot of people said it made things
worse I mean then you have Eric Holder
says it isn't interesting the Trump
supporters are Fanning these flames well
wasn't it interesting that Bill
Clinton's supporters were Fanning the
Cavanaugh flames and then the DNC chair
says oh nothing to see here this is just
like the Hillary email scandal okay well
why did Hillary delete 30,000 emails if
there wasn't anything to see speaking of
deleting The Associated Press admitted
they interviewed this woman read last
year spikes the story and then deleted
the files and now the Secretary of the
Senate says oh yeah you know that
complaint that we may or may not have
you can't see it because it's
confidential so the two places where the
complaint could be either in the
universe
Delaware the Senate file you're not
allowed to look into you've got to be
kidding me this thing is not over by a
mile
thinking I was going to do a call for
but I won't do it now because we're
short on time but there's a poll it
indicates that most Democrats favor
right now if it was up to them
the Massachusetts senator Elizabeth
Warren to be the vice president for Joe
Biden I wonder if you think all of these
allegations but or this specific
allegation there's not a bunch there's
one allegation against Biden is going to
impact the way that he calculates who's
gonna be his VP choice no cuz he'd
already settled on a woman and who
whomever he picks is gonna have to step
up and defend it but I I assume that the
media who already feel kind of toasty
and bubbly on the inside when they
interviewed Joe Biden will just skip
start skipping this question because
what in the more than two dozen
interviews that Biden did before Friday
after Tara Reed came out with her
allegations and what March 25th he never
even got asked about it so I think that
they will quickly pivot back to that but
it wasn't long ago that Joe Biden wasn't
in favor of the the accuser having a say
in a sexual assault allegation because
he put pressure on universities and
colleges in this country to basically
remove those protections for the accused
and actually called according to The
Wall Street Journal editorial called
Education Secretary Betsy DeVos when she
tried to restore due process on college
campuses called her and her supporters
cultural neanderthals that's worth
mentioning so Greg you know I I come to
you as a media master here Tara Reid has
not agreed to appear on talk show so
what do you think that's about and then
how do you cover it if she's not coming
back on television I don't know I mean
she did remember this was put out by
glenn greenwald's group so these are not
Republicans that are pushing this this
is actually progressives I think you
know I saw a prominent me too lawyer
sebelum did an open tweet to the accuser
yesterday saying hey I believe you Tara
Reed but I'm still supporting Joe Biden
and she even noted his handsy history of
touching people and basically what she
was saying is it's nothing personal it's
political and I thought how awful that
was until I realize holy crap she's
really honest she's actually an honest
liberal she's saying look I know Joe but
she's doing the exact opposite of all
the other Democrats so you say I know
he's guilty but I'm still gonna support
him because I hate Trump at least she's
being honest where's everybody else has
to bite their tongue because they want
to be VP they all want to be vice
president so all the women there go well
I support Joe Biden even though we've
heard everything everybody else is heard
finally we still haven't figured out how
to deal with this stuff in general like
how do you fight this in the public
square if he's innocent if Joe is
innocent as he was with Cavan as
Cavanaugh was then this is unfair and
bad it's just awful for him if he's
guilty then he must go but it's weird we
just don't have a solution for that do
we
so like dana says you'll have this back
and forth back and forth and then in a
week we'll just move on as if it never
happened like a weird you know like a
weird hangover and it's just gone and we
don't solve it because nobody really
cared well I think weevil cares but
you're right we don't have a good way to
solve that we can just vet you